a woman who's got a low body count who
doesn't go out and who looks good and it
will get challenged you can have it both
ways
you get a challenge so the thing is
instead of listening to what we want
you have to challenge it and then you
get confused about why men straight so
like when she's saying men will go for a
younger woman
the stats are there that men are more
attracted to younger women instead of
looking at it and saying okay well
that's that's the just the truth of the
matter the same way short men except
women like taller men
women need to accept that men have
certain standards and that is what the
facts are and the thing is why is it
that when when a woman tells a man this
is what I want the men got to listen
but when the man is saying this is what
I want the women like no no no no no no
no no no no no I don't think we were
saying that we don't accept I just don't
give up I don't I don't care she's like
it's not like correctly he is not the
only man in this world like I think in
this way cool like you're gonna find is
20 years old girl who can give free
child and whatever
like we are set in there we are setting
that we just think in a different way
which is a completely different thing
but if the cars we are certainly cool
like as I like a six foot guy and you
are setting it I'm fine with you getting
picking out at 20 years old girl peace
at 53 I'm looking good I can get any man
I want you know why because I have a low
body count but I'm going to be with all
the men wants you know what I mean
rubbish
you're
or the other ways they say they don't
care but if you're selling a car you
have to study the people you're selling
to and you don't go up to the people
that are buying and say oh you should
want me this is what you should want go
ahead the point I'm trying to make is
you're it's like you're assuming that
you're putting me in the books of people
that are saying oh no you can't want
that because I'm this way have me as I
am I never said that I said no I said
people should go for what they want if
you want a 20 something year old woman
go for that 20 Sovereign woman that
wants a fully 30 year old man if there's
a 30 year old woman or whatever who
can't have kids or doesn't want to have
kids or is too old to have kids or
whatever and she meets someone that is
happy to have her then that's like it
shouldn't be a combative thing where
it's like women don't listen and Men
listen and should have to settle and
should have to listen to what women want
blah blah blah if there's a man that is
four foot eight and he wants a tall
woman and the woman doesn't want him he
has to accept it if there's a woman
that's 37 38 and there's a guy who's
earning a lot of money tick soil boxes
he doesn't want her because she's old
she has to accept it that's the point in
the beginning was
you blame a man for stepping out if you
had given somebody else your best years
and this is why the men were saying what
the best years are but the women do not
want to hear from the men what the best
years are and when it comes to what the
best the best she is for the men biology
takes a main part of it so it doesn't
matter how old
and you guys were arguing about what the
best years were no because she said gave
your best years to someone else that's
where I was a bit what do you mean gave
my business yes
the experience it's the it's that whole
especially when you've had a child for
someone else especially I will say
majority of men Legacy is very important
do not yes there's a lot of baby mamas
around okay okay hold on hold on and
then this Falls in with the age thing as
well because as we're saying the old
you're getting the more Barren you're
becoming so then because you're older
you should accept that a man will cheat
on you is that is that what
you want to step out step out like when
we are fatty that's my value when you
say oh you're not 20 anymore so you
don't have any value no I actually my
value is that I can stand by my own I
can pay my bills I'm independent and
this is because I'm party because when I
was 20 I was probably looking for a man
to you know help me out in you know just
to in order to are you gonna be happy 60
without a family by yourself yeah
because in in the world I can do a lot
of things okay I can I can if I cannot
have my own baby I can adopt it I can
have a pet I can do whatever else I'm
not just a bloody baby machine honestly
I'm not a baby machine so my value
doesn't depend from how many eggs I
don't know I still don't I never found a
man that let me think okay let's have a
baby still so if I don't know I don't I
don't want to have a child I don't think
my life gonna be
saddling with the right man
it has to be the right man of course I'm
30 now right so I bet what I'm trying to
say is that if you find the right man
right at 35. yeah you get in a
relationship at 35.
when are you gonna think about having a
child no that can happen in six months
that can happen in two years time that's
not uh you know calendar and we don't
planify our life day by day that things
just happens and I just don't feel like
I'm less valuable than 20 years old I'm
just different so did you know one out
of three women under 30 have fertility
issues one out of everything our food is
different today so so I don't even know
if I want to tell it so like so I I know
but I'm saying for the right guy so if
you found the guy that that you would
have a kid with like that that's more of
a risk when you're older yeah it's free
to go with a 20 years old if you just
won't think about me as a baby machine
it's free to go either 20 years old but
one girl I'm fine
I'm just conscious about my age
yeah we're talking about baby right now
so I just answer the question you're
valued yeah explain to you I explained
to you just now that my value is not
about how many it when men I slept with
is not about how many eggs I contain
steel because I'm not a baby machine my
value is about how many money I can make
because I probably can make more money
than I meant out there it's about it's
about what I can deal with life every
day I don't need a man this is my value
okay I stand by my own this is my value
so the question is can you find a man
that can stand next to me and deal with
me yeah but when you say that's your
value to him who's that yeah for me I
don't I don't know
like when you're selling something she
talking about cars when you're selling
something is you you decide the value of
your